it took 50 days but joe biden and
democrats have finally passed their 1.9
trillion dollar covid relief build this
is the third relief
bill yeah since the start of the
pandemic
the house passed a version of the bill
previously
then the senate over the weekend passed
a slightly different version
that's the version which yesterday the
house of representatives
passed making this a done deal with joe
biden's imminent
signature the money will start going out
soon here is the moment that the bill
passed in the house of representatives
yesterday
on this vote the a's are 220
the nays are 211.
the motion is adopted
[Applause]
section of motion
now you will note that the bill passed
with 220 democratic yes votes
one democrat voting no and all
republicans who voted voting no not a
single republican voted for the covid
relief bill in the senate
not a single republican voted for the
covid relief bill in the house of
representatives
75 percent of the country which means
tens of millions of republican voters 75
percent of the country
supports the bill and yet not one
republican voting in favor who
exactly are republicans representing
because clearly they are not
representing their own constituents
but let's focus on what is in the bill
there's the part for individuals and
then there's the part
for state governments and organizations
for individuals
there will be cash payments up to
fourteen hundred dollars for people
earning up to 80 000 or 120
000 for single parents or 160 000
for couples now to get the full 1400 the
income limit is 75k
per person it will start phasing out but
you get
something all the way up to 80 000 as an
individual
120 000 if you are a single parent and
160 000 in income
for couples dependent college students
and dependent older relatives
also count here that was not the case in
previous bills
enhanced unemployment is part of this
300
per week of extra unemployment above and
beyond what your
state offers if you are unemployed that
is extended through the 6th
of september and then up to 10
200 of unemployment benefits
received in 2020 are tax-free
for household incomes up to a hundred
and fifty thousand dollars
in general um unemployment benefits are
taxable income
subject to your total family's household
income
in general you pay taxes on unemployment
income if you earn 140 000
a year in income because that is um a
tax bracket at which
you pay taxes in this particular case up
to ten thousand two hundred dollars of
unemployment benefits from last year
would be tax-free assuming your
household income is under a hundred and
fifty thousand
the child tax credit is being increased
up to three thousand dollars per child
and thirty six hundred dollars for kids
five years of
age and under and the limit of the age
limit for the
child tax credit also being increased
from 16 to 17
which will include many additional
children so there's a few other things
for individuals that's the bulk of what
has been passed for individuals
maybe like you depending on your
financial and family
situation and then at the larger level
the bill also includes among other
things 350 billion dollars for state
local and tribal
governments for pandemic response and
reaction
10 billion dollars for critical state
infrastructure
14 billion dollars for vaccine
distribution very important
130 billion dollars for primary and
secondary schools
very important and this will come up
again later schools that want to open
but they need money in order to be able
to do the things that the cdc
has designated should be done for
schools to open safely
30 billion dollars for transit agencies
also very much affected by low ridership
as a result of the pandemic
and 45 billion dollars in rental utility
and mortgage assistance
so it took 50 days it's 1400
totaling 2 000 if you include the
stimulus from six months ago
rather than two thousand dollars doesn't
include the fifteen dollar minimum wage
but republicans wanted to pass nothing
and we have this ongoing question will
republicans be held accountable by
voters electorally
nearly two years from now in 2022
i believe the answer is no even though
75 percent of the country wants the bill
and not a single republican voted for it
um
voters have short memories quite frankly
that that's basically what it is uh i
even think that
if the 2020 election had been in 2021
even in november of 2021 i think things
will have been better enough
that donald trump's disastrous handling
of the pandemic might not
actually have seen him removed from
office that's how short i believe
voter memories are particularly
republicans who go back very quickly
to these sort of reflexive and
meaningless meaningless anti-left
talking points but that is what is in
the bill we expect money to start going
out
possibly within 48 hours of joe biden's
signature
which is imminent maybe even happening
today maybe it will already have
happened even
by the time you listen to today's show
or watch this
clip the more we learn about various
diets
around the world the more we realize
that
some of the healthiest diets where folks
are living the healthiest than the
longest
are heavily plant-based and one of our
sponsors
just egg is a great place to start just
egg
cooks and tastes just like real eggs
but it's made from plants it has less
saturated fat
no cholesterol packed with protein i've
been cooking with just
egg at home and you can use it
in so many different ways just like
traditional eggs omelettes scrambled
eggs french toast
banana bread one of my favorite dishes
pad thai
it also is better for the planet
generating 93
fewer carbon emissions and 98 percent
less water than conventional eggs
you can find just egg at lots of grocery
stores whole foods
kroger amazon prime now and instacart
check it out just egg really is a great
product from a company with a great
mission
and i'm really glad that they're a
sponsor of the show